j'avais pas j'avais pas trouvé j'ai pas
d'autres solutions en fait ça fait
vraiment besoin d'argent sur le coup et
c'était la seule solution qui s'est
présentée à moi en fait
[Musique]
le profil type
on le connaît à peu près tous c'est
plutôt jeune moyenne d'âge 25 ans homme
ou femme
et en général personne sans emploi ou
avec un emploi précaire facile à
convaincre pour transporter la cocaïne
on parle de la mule je dirais un peu
standard et qui transporte donc soit
dans les bagages mais qui peut
transporter aussi à l'intérieur du corps
en ovule la cocaïne
[Musique]
là tout ça c'est des ovules
ils ne connaissent pas vraiment les
complications qui peuvent résulter de
cette crise de cocaïne donc quand on
commence à leur expliquer des fois ils
prennent conscience de ce qu'ils ont
fait il y en a qui ce matin pleurer
d'autres qui ne parlent pas qui ne
répondent pas donc qui se fige et qui se
braque à son répondra et on a des gens
qui se mettent à pleurer qui ne
s'arrêtent plus c'est parce que c'est le
moment où il réalise qu'ils ont fait une
bêtise et qui vont aller en prison
de la distance avec les gens les gens
que je côtoyais des gens qui appréciais
qui m'appréciais ça la perte de temps
beaucoup de perte de temps
[Musique]
en Guyane 53% de la population vous vit
sous un seuil de pauvreté on a 45 % de
vie chers et les gens n'arrivent pas à
s'en sortir en fait ils arrivent pas à
boucler les fins de moi en travaillant
tout ça
[Musique]